anyone who thinks this is the last
global pandemic America will face lack
sufficient imagination there's no
question this will happen again in a
world connected by jet travel that is
guaranteed so as we suffer through this
virus maybe we should learn something
useful for the next time going forward
our leaders ought to be certain we have
enough medicine and tests and hospital
beds at the least in case something
awful happens unexpectedly because it
will there should be a plan to respond
quickly in ways that assure the public
that the people in charge know what
they're doing those are the obvious
lessons from the epidemic now in
progress but there's more to learn here
a few other things to think about
first borders matter it turns out that
immigration isn't some boutique
political issue that only activists need
to care about the question of who lives
in your country is the most basic issue
that any nation faces ever immediately
after the corona virus began to spread
globally same countries started to
secure their borders they wanted to know
exactly who was coming in and out and
they wanted to control it that was the
first thing they did in Israel where
leaders care deeply about their country
border controls were Swift and highly
aggressive the Israelis did not want a
single person who was even potentially
infected to cross into Israel and good
for them unfortunately nothing like that
could ever happen here in the US
Democrats were denounced instantly as
racist and xenophobic so it'd be Nancy
Pelosi will give us a stern lecture
about how immoral Israel is we'll be
waiting for that speech probably forever
next gun control takes on new
significance when things fall apart it
doesn't take much for a law in order to
collapse civilization itself can
evaporate quickly and over the centuries
it often has on some level all of us
know this we're animals with a
collective memory of prior chaos
embedded in our genes so at times like
this were reminded how precarious any
society is given that you've got to
wonder about our leaders demands that we
disarm
anyone who increases the threat to you
and your family and at the same time
tries to prevent you from defending
yourself is your enemy by definition
it's scary when you think about that in
the context of what is happening now and
apparently a lot of people have thought
about it ammunition sales jumped by
hundreds of percent this week if
Americans really believe their leaders
would protect them when it came down to
it that wouldn't be happening and
speaking of our leaders who's really in
charge of this country we think we know
the answer the people on the ballot at
election time but if you want to know
who's actually in control of anything
ask yourself who can make you beg for
mercy if one of your kids had a bad
infection you would do anything for
antibiotics but our leaders don't
control those drugs China does the
Chinese manufacturer our entire supply
of antibiotics not to mention countless
other goods your family literally could
not live without and here's the worst
news the Chinese hate us and have
threatened to withhold life-saving
medicine from us our most powerful enemy
in the world
has the power of life and death over our
country we should not let a single day
pass before fixing this but we should
also recognize that not all of our
opponents are foreign in the next few
months American hospitals are likely to
overflow with the desperately ill it's
possible that many people who need
immediate care will be turned away to
suffer and die that's a horrifying
prospect so does this seem like the
right time to open our entire health
care system to the rest of the world for
free what would happen to sick people in
America if we did that it sounds like a
form of sabotage if that's exactly what
every Democrat who ran for president
proposed in public even now as we face
an unprecedented strain on our health
care system thanks to coronavirus they
have not changed their view on that what
are they thinking well they're not
thinking they're believing believing
fervently in the cult of identity
politics Joe Biden released his plan for
coronavirus today the first bullet point
proclaims this quote acts of racism and
xenophobia against the Asian American
and Pacific Islander community must not
be tolerated that's number one on
Biden's list is racism against the quote
Pacific Islander community really our
country's most urgent problem right now
no it is not is not even in the top 500
problems you're not gonna see angry mobs
lynching people in the streets because
of coronavirus you never will see that
it won't happen here this is not that
kind of country America is a welcoming
place filled with unusually kind and
open-hearted people
the merchants of woke desks cannot see
that they refuse to see it as a matter
of faith they believe that all bad
things emanate from America they will
always put America last it's their Creed
Biden's plan goes on to demand that we
change the Trump administration
so-called public charge rule changing
that would allow more penniless
immigrants to move into this country at
taxpayer expense and use our already
dangerously overburdened health care
system in the middle of a terrible
epidemic how does that help it doesn't
help it hurts that's the point of it
people like this are dangerous they're
the reason things are falling apart
suddenly they seem to run everything but
they are not in the majority in this
country and we should remember that most
Americans are not cult members they're
not ideological they're sensible they
understand what our leaders need to do
they need to treat us as we would treat
our own children if there's a threat to
your kids you don't pause to think of an
excuse or pretend it's not happening you
act you do whatever is necessary to
protect them period if you die trying it
is a life well spent if you're forced to
choose between your own children and the
kids next door you understand that's not
really a choice you have only one duty
to the lives in your care your people
the ones who depend on you in the end
that's what it means to lead a family it
means no less to lead a country instead
of protecting the people of this country
our leaders top priority is condemning
fake as NF obeah and making certain they
can't be called racist on Twitter